[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres ce soir nous avons le plaisir
et l'honneur de recevoir l'expression de
la palu plaire le pape de la vie
intellectuelle française de ce de ce
pontificat il a les trois attributs
majeurs l'université il a enseigné à
Sciences Po et ensuite dans la très
prestigieuse École des hautes études en
sciences sociales l'édition il est le
pilier de la maison d'édition la plus
fameuse et la plus puissante Gallimard
et enfin les médias il a cheminé
longtemps aux côtés du Nouvel
Observateur de Jean-Daniel à l'époque où
cette hebdomadaire était l'arbitre des
bienséances culturels françaises mais
pour être au coeur du pouvoir
intellectuel français il n'en est pas
pour autant un mandarin il n'a pas
fabriqué d'école il n'a pas placé ses
obligés et il n'a pas organisé le culte
de sa personnalité il n'a pas distribué
les indulgences ou prononcer les
anathèmes non tout au contraire il a mis
son intelligence et son énergie au
service des idées des œuvres des livres
de toute une génèse de plusieurs
générations
d'intellectuels qu'il a soit éditer soit
entraîné dans l'aventure dont on parlera
des lieux de mémoire il est en somme un
témoin et un acteur majeur de la vie
intellectuelle de ces 50 dernières
années et c'est de cela dont nous allons
parler avec lui ce soir qu'il y en aura
bonsoir bonsoir je devrais d'ailleurs
vous appeler maître parce que vous êtes
académicien français
vous publiez une étrange obstination
vous aviez il y a un an fait paraître
jeunesse qui était comme le premier tome
de ce travail sur lequel on va revenir
et vous y racontiez votre éducation
sentimentale et intellectuel dans une
étrange obstination vous revenez sur
votre vie d'homme non pas du point de
vue personnel mais du point de vue de
votre travail d'universitaire
d'historien et d'éditeur mais vous avez
d'ailleurs précisé que ça n'était pas
des mémoires pourquoi est-ce que le mot
de mémoire vous gêne
une solennité trop grande parce que j'en
ai étudié le genre et à l'occasion d'un
article des lieux de mémoire sur les
mémoires d'État
j'ai été aperçu d'ailleurs que il n'y
avait pas de livre général sur le genre
mémoire que d'une part les historiens
les étudiés pour leur faire dire les
mensonges qu'il recelait et les
littéraires uniquement pour les qualités
esthétiques mais que ce genre qui est un
des plus importants de la tradition
depuis des siècles en France n'avait pas
été étudié comme tel et constituée
effectivement quand on analysait un lieu
de mémoire voilà pourquoi impressionnez
moi-même par la tradition que j'avais
raconté je ne me soutais pas digne de
m'inscrire dans jeunesse j'en dis je
reviens d'un mot dans jeunesse parce
qu'il y a une chose qui me paraît
incroyable vous venez d'une famille de
bourgeoisie ordinaire votre famille
venait de Lorraine votre père était tout
à fait non ordinaire mais je veux dire
c'est sans méchanceté ou son enfin une
famille de la bourgeoisie votre père est
un médecin hospitalier mais où qu'on se
tourne en regardant autour de vous il
n'y a que des grands esprits votre frère
c'est si mon oral l'icône de la haute
fonction publique votre cousin c'est
André Meyer qui a non non
ce qui a dirigé la banque là vers votre
autre cousin par alliance c'est François
Jacob qui est prix Nobel votre ami
jeunesse et Pierre vide alnaquer votre
beau-frère c'est François Furet à la
génération d'après votre nièce dirige le
Nouvel Observateur votre neveu Olivier
Norin est un brillant éditeur c'est
quelle est la recette magique d'où ça
vient quel est le secret de cette
famille
mon père
mon père qui a été un homme
de fortes personnalité
et qui
a été entraîné dans la guerre pendant la
première où il a été mobilisé pendant 7
ans de 1913 à 1920 et qui
a vécu pour la médecine pour le devoir
et pour l'éducation de ses enfants
pour lesquelles il était sans doute très
ambitieux il voyait son aîné Simon dont
vous avez parlé comme un futur ministre
au moins et président de la République
éventuelle
son deuxième fils qui était médecin un
grand médecin de l'hôpital c'est un
grand service hospitalier
j'avais une sœur aussi mais c'était
l'époque où il y avait un tel mépris
chez ces machos que du moment qu'elle
était jolie on pourrait la marier alors
que c'était la personne à laquelle la
plus forte de l'âme
fratrie et qu'elle aurait pu faire des
études et que leur aurait pu faire du
tout d'autres carrière et qu'elle a été
comme amputé dès le départ dans sa vie
par ces trois frères qui l'ont écrasé
son père et sa mère il a pas joué à oui
le rôle qu'elle aurait dû jouer pour la
défendre et pour faire une solidarité
féminine et puis bois que mon père
souvenais ce que j'ai des bons en
français mais voyez un petit peu comme
un grand écrivain Anatole France ou
Marcel Proust plutôt qu'il n'avait
d'ailleurs pas lu lui-même et voilà il a
élevé ses enfants comme ça avec un
surmoi
une très fort une exigence très haute
alors dans une étrange obstination on va
venir maintenant à votre trajectoire
intellectuelle à votre vie d'éditeur et
d'historien
[Musique]
au début des années 60 vous êtes un
jeune historien un jeune agrégé vous
avez publié un livre les Français
d'Algérie qui a fait grand bruit vous
avez créé une collection d'histoire
archives assez originales et qui elle
aussi va connaître un grand succès et la
maison Gallimard vous propose alors de
développer son département de sciences
humaines et vous allez créer en effet
des collections de sciences humaines et
d'histoire qui vont connaître un essor
considérable et d'ailleurs modifier
l'assise de Gallimard qui était la
grande maison littéraire j'ai une
Malraux etc pour devenir la grande
maison littéraire et la grande maison de
sciences humaines la question que je me
suis posée en vous lisant c'est pourquoi
vous avez été le témoin et l'acteur de
l'avènement presque de la naissance des
sciences humaines au milieu des années
60 les disciplines existaient déjà la
sociologie mais tout à coup elle se
s'agglomère elles font bloc et elle
domine la vie intellectuelle elles vont
la dominer pendant 20 ans pourquoi
il y a eu pour de ma part de mon côté
une
coïncidence très heureuse entre
mon entrée chez Gallimard et et l'époque
et j'étais pas du tout étranger au monde
que j'ai été amené à publier puisque
j'en faisais partie je pourrai pas être
éditeur de musique ou de littérature
enfantine je n'ai au fond publié que
ceux que j'ai connu en quelque sorte et
puis l'époque qui est la plus importante
j'ai coïncidé
avec une époque heureuse
soudaine et qui s'est terminée ce qu'on
a appelé les il y a eu les 30 années
glorieuses de l'économie et il y a eu
les 30 années glorieuses de la vie
intellectuelle et
de l'histoire en particulier qui est
apparu comme fédératrice
de chacune des sciences humaines qui
elles-mêmes se sont révélo grand public
à ce moment-là le
logis par exemple à travers les bistrots
la linguistique à travers
babyniste et mille babigny
les
il y a eu une sorte la psychologie et la
psychanalyse à travers Lacan et
des philosophes comme Foucault ont
immédiatement paru comme une sorte de
nouveaux personnes français et qui
occupait le terrain et
la caractéristique de tout cela c'est
que ces sciences humaines sont sortis de
leur spécialités ont éclaté dans le
public et ont plus même dans leur
ensemble l'espoir d'une science de
l'homme science humaine et d'une unité
de
connaissance de l'homme il y a eu la
belle hélusion au fond et puis au bout
du trentaine d'années quand le monde la
dernière
dernier élément
il faut prendre en compte je crois pour
comprendre l'éclosion ludique de cette
période c'est la guerre c'est la
post-guerre c'est et ces fréquents dans
toute les après-guerre c'est après la
Révolution française que tout d'un coup
le romantisme a pu éclater littéralement
c'est après la guerre de 70 qu'une
formidable période intellectuelle et
a pu sortir la génération des qui dit
des proustes on peut pas comprendre tout
ça sans le désabs 70 et là il y a eu 45
certainement qui a généré cette
effervescence
bobontanée mais flamboyante à laquelle
j'ai pu assister et que j'ai en partie
en partie orchestrée c'est à dire que la
période va porter et je l'ai un peu
porté alors vous d'où vous l'avez dit
l'histoire et comme la discipline
maîtresse de cet ensemble que j'étais
historien et donc et alors en effet on
voit que Montaillou village occitan
thèse assez complexe de le roi Ladurie
est un best-seller oui que un dimanche à
Bouvines de Duby fait de le rendre
glorieux que poncer la Révolution
française de François Furet un coup de
tonnerre mais c'est pas l'histoire
traditionnelle l'histoire qui dont
l'avènement est contemporain de cette
période c'est une histoire qui remet
l'histoire oui oui elle a déjà à vrai
dire elle a été remise déjà avant la
guerre par cette trilogie d'homme
Lucien Faivre Marc Bloch
essentiellement mais beaucoup d'autres
j'ai dit Trilogis j'aurais dû dire
binomie mais
ils avaient travaillé dans leur coin
l'histoire dites nouvelles qui
consistait tout simplement pour tout
dire à
écarter ouvrir enrichir une histoire qui
jusqu'à lors paraissait assez linéaire
politique
et où il y avait des causes
des conséquences et un événement à
raconter donc une priorité du récit des
événements essentiellement politiques
militaire et parce que la guerre régnait
diplomatique parce que c'était les
hommes diplomatiques qui organisaient la
société
et les régimes et les nations mais qui
était assez pauvre dans sa problématique
et chacune des sciences humaines dont je
viens de vous parler à nourri
phénoménalement l'histoire et qui du
coup
déplu la même en effet et c'est enrichi
de la sociologie de la géographie de la
psychologie de la sociologie c'est ça
qui a fait par exemple vous évolue
parler de de Montaillou village occitan
c'est c'est là qui au moment de
l'occitan de la poussée de l'Occitanie
entre le 14ème siècle et le 15e
qui est la première renaissance de
l'Occitanie a permis de faire sur un
petit village
une sorte d'histoire on appelait à
l'époque totale alors vous vous
inscrivez-vous même dans ce mouvement et
d'ailleurs vous allez contribuer à son
renouvellement parce qu'à côté de votre
travail d'éditeur vous avez vous allez
vous lancer au début des années 80 dans
une entreprise qui va déjà effrayer la
maison Gallimard vous inventez le
concept de lieu de mémoire on va revenir
sur ce concept et à partir de là vous
dirigez une oeuvre encyclopédique autour
de la République la France la nation et
la France cette volumes
plusieurs centaines d'entrée de
d'articles des dizaines de contributeurs
quelle est l'idée qui a présidé d'abord
comment elle vous est venu c'est pas un
inventaire à la Prévert que vous êtes en
train d'évoquer
comme on dit work in progresse
c'est-à-dire qui du départ s'est
développé progressivement comme une
plante et ce qui
au début du début et là aussi cette
invention j'ose pas dire je ne cherche
pas le mot le c'est pas un concept non
plus cette notion c'est plus modeste de
mémoire et était une
invasion de l'époque elle-même
ce serait long à décrire en quelques
mots mais la France à l'époque a connu
une
montée en puissance de ce que l'on a
appelé la mémoire et en particulier pour
aller vite la mémoire des anciens
minoritaires c'est-à-dire les ouvriers
les Juifs les femmes les provinciaux etc
etc qui ont
jusqu'à lors
exprimé leur propre mémoire personnelle
particulière familiale sociale
chez eux pour eux
et qui tout d'un coup éclate dans le
public il suffit de songer à ce que les
Juifs étaient
de songeait qu'à se faire en gros
oubliés ou à devenir Français plus que
les Français
jusque à ischman et qui a révélé la
spécificité d'une horreur qu'il aurait
été
affecté spécialement et qui du coup a
provoqué une une prise de conscience de
la singularité de la chose les femmes
même chose le mouvement féministe etc
donc je suis là aussi au moment je me
courbe ou de voir d'une mémoire qui me
dépassait et je l'applique à l'histoire
alors c'est
effectivement quand j'ai dû aux études
étudier
l'idée nationale ce qu'on appelait sur
lequel il y avait des livres très
nombreux et qui racontait l'histoire des
idées il m'a paru beaucoup plus
intéressant de prendre des phénomènes
quels qu'ils soient de toute nature que
j'ai appelé des lieux évidemment et qui
pouvait être des lieux matériels mais
des lieux tout à fait immatériels comme
la génération par exemple et
ou l'amour de la patrie ou
des lieux emblématiques comme
les symboles de Paris
et
mais aussi une multiplicité de
phénomène comme le Larousse tous les
dictionnaires ne sont pas des lieux de
mémoire d'une certaine façon le
dictionnaire Larousse en étain ou le
malaisisa qui était pour l'histoire une
forme de lieu alors j'y suis allé au
départ extrêmement
intuitivement
progressivement et vraiment il m'avait
paru beaucoup plus intéressant d'étudier
ce qui s'attachait du sentiment national
à ce type d'objet extrêmement divers qui
devenait des sortes de mémoriaux
tests mais de l'idée nationale se
faisant vous avez quand même
révolutionné en cas de transformer la
discipline l'historiographique
totalement parce qu'au lieu de le fait
au lieu de prendre les grandes
continuités les grandes unités tout à
coup on s'est intéressé à des éléments
signifiants significatif que j'ai appelé
lieu et qui est encore une fois elle
couvrait un très large éventail de
choses alors au départ ça a été un
instrument de compréhension et
différents de de la mémoire nationale et
à la fin ça a été une histoire de la
France par la mémoire et est-ce que
enfin c'est une interprétation abusive
parce que je vais mettre en parallèle de
choses qui vont vous horrifier mais il y
a deux phénomènes qui arrivent en même
temps la montée du Front national de
l'extrême droite et le développement des
lieux de mémoire autrement dit on a
l'impression que on arrive vous arrivez
à une époque où l'identité nationale se
dissout en identité particulière vous
l'avez dit régional confessionnelle de
gens de d'origine et où l'histoire
traditionnelle se dissout dans les
mémoires donc au fond les lieux votre
aventure intellectuelle reflète quoi un
essoufflement du modèle français une
fatigue démocratique une c'est ça que
cette éclosion des mémoires traduit oui
je crois que un déchu raison du succès
de cette entreprise a été multiple d'un
côté vous le rappeliez le Front national
en effet à chercher à sanexer les lieux
de mémoire en me faisant des appels du
pied auquel j'ai pas répondu et
d'autres côtés
ça apparut comme
un enterrement de la France une sorte de
tombeau comme on dit au sens sépulcral
du mot grand soleil couchant voilà le
grand soleil le chant du signe de la de
l'identité nationale
et moi je pense que
expliquer ainsi
les phénomènes
les fonds revivent au contraire c'est
comme les
ethnologues à qui on reprocher quelques
fois que mettre les mythes
en explication était une façon de les de
les enterrer de leur donner le moment
final de même alors que c'est en même
temps le seul moyen de le de le
revitaliser et et je pense que c'est par
la mémoire que se revitalisent des
symboles comme le drapeau français le
plus simple dernière grande œuvre la
revue Le Débat que vous avez créé il y a
40 ans et auquel vous avez mis un terme
comment vous résumeriez en quelques mots
cette aventure de la revue Le Débat
bien je dirais que cette entreprise a
correspondu à la fin de l'idée
révolutionnaire
pendant laquelle les intellectuels se
consacraient à transformer le monde ou à
vouloir le faire
tandis que cette sortie de l'âge
révolutionnaire dans les années 80
précisément du siècle dernier
ont été le moment où les intellectuels
se sont convertis à la démocratie par
déception de l'échec de l'Union
soviétique en particulier et
ont commencé à comprendre que la
démocratie supposait beaucoup deux
choses savoir qu'on allait vivre avec
des gens qui ne pensaient pas comme vous
et donc discuter plutôt que les
exterminés
et deuxièmement que le monde qui
arrivait qui était si différent du
précédent et si complexe dans toutes ces
aspects
exiger que les intellectuels s'attachent
n'ont pas à vouloir transformer le monde
mais à le comprendre je crains
malheureusement que cette époque ne soit
évolue et c'est peut-être pour ça que
vous avez mis vous-même un terme à la
revue Le Débat malheureusement pierre
j'aurais bien aimé continuer à bavarder
discuter avec vous j'avais encore bien
des sujets sur lequel j'aurais aimé vous
entendre notamment l'évolution des
sciences humaines aujourd'hui mais on
recommencera en attendant on ne peut pas
discuter de tout on ne peut pas non plus
inviter tous les auteurs mais on peut
recommander dire quels sont les ouvrages
qui nous ont frappés c'est dans ces
dernières heures ou ces derniers jours
quel est le livre vous que vous
recommanderiez à ceux qui nous ont
écouté et bien chez lui la même que le
journal Le Monde m'a fait découvrir
par un très bel article sur un auteur
que peu connu en France et qu'ils
appellent Ferdinand bonne
Sarah que le monde comparait un peu à un
mot passant en français et autrichien
c'est pas faux c'est l'histoire du
lieutenant Fulda est à la fois le déclin
de l'empire autrichien et
les difficultés sociales
qui s'y exprime à travers le destin d'un
militaire amoureux d'une femme dont la
condition sociale lui est supérieure
alors pour notre part nous vous
recommandons la lecture enfin nous avons
aimé la lecture mais c'est un peu pour
vous qu'on le cite vinoc gouvernait la
France il est l'expression de ces
historiens dont vous parlez il traverse
à travers ce livre l'ensemble des
tumultes et des évolutions comment dire
oui
violente et pas violente de notre vie
politique ça nous permet de regarder
avec un peu de distance ce qui nous
arrive aujourd'hui c'est un des aspects
de vie là qu'il y en a d'autres il y a
le biographes en particulier qui mérite
aussi d'être exalté
Jean-Claude Grimbert Jacqueline
Jacqueline en fait il sort en édition de
poche ça c'est l'édition
l'édition la première édition je sais
pas si vous avez lu ça piano rein c'est
un une merveilleuse ode à l'amour c'est
Jean-Claude Grimbert qui est un grand
auteur de théâtre et qui fait un
portrait un éloge de la femme qui n'a
pas dans la qui n'a pas assez déclaré
son amour pendant sa vie c'est
merveilleux je vous l'offre
Pascal Robert Diard la petite menteuse
Pascal Robert est l'excellente
chroniqueuse judiciaire du monde et elle
revient à ses époques De Mitou c'est
assez courageux de sa part elle revient
sur une affaire qu'elle a transformé en
fiction mais d'une jeune fille d'une
enfant qui a dénoncé quelqu'un pour
crime sexuel après de se ravi avant de
se raviser et de d'expliquer qu'elle
avait mon fils à sa crée le doute qui
est si nécessaire dans le traitement des
affaires judiciaires le respect de la
présomption d'innocence et enfin une
bande dessinée tirée du livre de Diane
du film de Diane currys diabolo monde
c'est puisque chaque semaine nous vous
recommandons aussi des bandes dessinées
c'est celle-là que nous vous
recommandons voilà notre émission
s'achève merci à Pierre Nora d'avoir
bien voulu nous promener à vous dans un
domicile de vie intellectuelle merci à
vous qui nous avait suivi vous pouvez
revoir cette émission sur le site de
Public Sénat ou sur vos plateformes
préférées sous la forme de podcast et
nous nous retrouvons la semaine
prochaine même chaîne même heure même
jour sauf si d'ici là nous sommes
croisés dans une librairie merci et
bonsoir
[Musique]